some of China's largest cities are
easing coveted restrictions while police
are also watching for any new protests
you saw them over the weekend thousands
of people blasting the government's
coveted policies in China's largest
public demonstrations in decades now the
government may be trying to defuse
public anger and prevent a larger
outbreak of protests Holly Williams
lived and worked in China for more than
a decade and she shows us now how the
newest protests bring back memories of a
much more turbulent time 33 years ago
down with the Communist party they
shouted on the streets of Shanghai an
eruption of anger against a one-party
state in power for over 70 years
takes courage to go out to straighter
protest
is a Chinese journalist based in London
she says the last time China saw
anything like this was in 1989.
when University students LED
demonstrations in beijing's Tiananmen
Square this is the first time since 1989
we've seen protesters explicitly calling
for the downfall of the Communists this
is the first time so this is huge this
is huge yeah
Zhang led a pro-democracy protest
herself in 1989 in the southern city of
Nanjing and says she was interrogated by
the police and how dangerous is it to
hold a protest like that in China
calling for the downfall of the
Communist Party very likely those
leaders who leaded chance will ended up
in prison or maybe even worse
the Tiananmen protest ended with a
ruthless Crackdown
a bloody massacre carried out by China's
military but Zhang says the upheaval in
1989
forced China's leaders to give their
people more personal and economic
freedom it's been a recipe for Success
until recently with heavy-handed covert
restrictions forcing entire
neighborhoods into quarantine Chinese
people have a reputation being gentle or
even those are but the people are not
stupid
in 1989 did you learn something about
the ruthlessness of the Communist Party
certainly yes until the last minute we
did not believe that the government
would really opened fire to some people
and the lesson is they they would do
anything
to preserve their power
Zhang lija told us if China's government
is smart it'll ease covert restrictions
and there are signs that may already be
happening if it doesn't she says there
will be more protests Nate
it does seem like we were in covet
lockdowns here just yesterday Holly
Williams thank you